extra extra Sheriff raid's smalltown
newspaper for First Amendment activity
it's almost impossible to believe the
police chief of a small Kansas town
ordered a raid on a weekly newspaper
called the Maran County record in the
home of its publisher the police claimed
that the reporters broke the law while
investigating a restaurant owner who had
a history of drunk driving what the hell
the newspaper's co-owner 98-year-old
Joan Meyer died the next day however
days after the raid the district
attorney withdrew the search for
acknowledging that it lacks probable
cause Eric Meyer is the publisher of the
newspaper which he Co own with his
mother Joan the trouble began when the
town hire Gideon Cody is police chief in
April of 2023 Cody left a job in Kansas
City that paid him $15,000 a year to
take the job in Maran paying $60,000 a
year Meyer said he received anonymous
tips on a variety of tales about why
Cody took such a big pay cut to move to
Maran tipsters said he was accused of
sexual misconduct reporters investigated
the tips but meer said the newspaper
could not verify them to its
satisfaction so Meer approached Cody
before he was sworn in his chief and
asked him about it uh Chief Cody told
him quote if you print that I will sue
you and in May reporters started looking
into allegations that Mary and rester on
tour Carrie Newell had been driving on a
suspended license Newell was in the
midst of applying for a liquor license
for her catering business she had also
purchased a restaurant and that liquor
license was up for renewal in August but
state law prohibits such licenses being
issued to applicants with felony drunk
driving convictions or multiple alcohol
related convictions within a certain
time frame and a source reached out to
the porters via social media The Source
also sent information to councilwoman
Ruth herbel who served as vice mayor
reporter philis Zorn verified the
information about new's license was
accurate by conducting a driver's
license record search on the department
of revenue's website using new's first
and last name and the driver's license
number for new that the record had
received from its source the results
showed the tip about new's record was
accurate new's license was ordered
suspended because of a drunken driving
conviction in 2008 and a series of other
driving convictions and apparently the
information received by herbal and the
record listed conditions nle would have
to meet to have her license reinstated
one of them was installation of an
anti-drinking ignition interlock on any
vehicle that she drove however the
record decided not to publish the
information because Meyer suspected the
anonymous source may have been new's
arranged husband Town needs car's
business you know this is a dispute
between her and her estranged husband
Meer said he did not want the newspaper
to be used in a divorce dispute quote
instead the newspaper consulted an
attorney and without naming new last
week notified the sheriff and Marian's
police chief that it had received the
material from someone who had bragged
about retaining connections despite no
longer working in law enforcement when
reporters from the Maran record showed
up to a public forum Newell was hosting
with representative Jake lerer Newell
called the police who told the reporter
to leave why'd you kick him
out for their reporting and a few weeks
later Newell went before the city
council and accused the record of
spreading lies about her it was brought
to my attention today that my private
and personal information that was
illegally attained obtained by a local
reporter was shared with council member
Ruth herble take note of exactly how
vile your behavior this is going to be
placed with the county attorney because
this is going to become a case that's
why the council voted 4 to one to give
Newell her liquor license herbal was the
only person who voted against new the
restaurant New operates has a license
under the name of the former owner Tammy
Ensley eny owns the hotel affiliated
with the restaurant and happens to be
the sister-in-law of District Attorney
Joel Ensley uh nle was set to go before
the city council on August 7th and just
days later on August 11th Chief Cody
obtained search warrants for the
newspaper's office the Publisher's home
and the vice mayor's house the affidavit
authorizing the searches and Caesar were
signed by Magistrate Judge Laura V he
bragged to uh an officer on his staff
that this was going to be the biggest
raid that Maran county has ever seen now
here's a video of the raid on Meyer's
house
don't you touch any of that
stuff this is my house that's Joan Meyer
on the left who passed away the next day
and in a strange twist magistrate V also
has two DUIs on her criminal record but
now we learn that the judge herself also
has two DUIs those incidents both
happened in 2012 in Morris and coffee
counties she also had a suspended
driver's license when news of the raid
broke it made International headlines
because it's so rare for police to raid
a newsroom Eric Meer described Cody as a
bully saying that he reached out to
notify the police that quote a source
had given us a file that we thought had
suspicious Origins we checked it out to
verify that it was accurate but were not
planning to do anything with it their
response was the typical fashion of a
bully instead of asking a question or
getting material they came with an
atomic fly water to seize our equipment
and apparently tried to put us out of
business and yeah this is exactly what
laws protecting the Free Press are meant
to prevent now Kansas Law requires a
search warrant application to be
supported by an affidavit a search
warrant shall be issued only upon the
oral or written statement including
those conveyed or received by electronic
communication but a person under oath or
affirmation which states facts
sufficient to show probable cause that a
crime has been is being or is about to
be committed and which particularly
describes a person place or means of
conveyance to be searched and things to
be seized now the local Court repeatedly
told the media that the affidavits
weren't available yet and finally on
August 16th Marian County Attorney Joel
Ensley withdrew the search warrant on
the newspaper and the Meer home citing
insufficient evidence to support the
alleged crimes and seizures the warrant
on herbal home has not been withdrawn
and the police haven't returned her
property now eny said his review of the
case found quote insufficient evident
exists to establish a legally sufficient
Nexus between the alleged crime and the
places searched and the item seized as a
result I have submitted a proposed order
asking the court to release the evidence
seiz now the media only obtained the
warrant affidavit after eny withdrew the
warrant Newell told the police chief
that quote on a phone call from 87 2023
at or around 1901 hours Eric Meyer
admitted to her that an employee of his
philis sorn downloaded the private do
record information and that is why there
would be no story Cody then writes that
Newell told him quot Eric then
threatened her if you say anything I
will print the story and I will continue
to use anything I can to come at you I
will own your restaurant now obviously
nle has animosity towards Meyer but does
Cody well the affidavit says quote I
received an email from Eric Meer in the
email he states that he received a copy
of someone's private Department of
Revenue records in the email he alleged
possible police misconduct regarding how
the Department of Revenue record was
obtained so Cody maintains or
misapprehended that the dror records are
private when that's not really the case
and the fact that he perceived Meyer's
call as alleging police misconduct makes
this look like a pretextual search
especially since Cody was already mad
that the newspaper was investigating
sexual misconduct allegations and in the
affidavit Newell says that the reporters
invaded her private mail uh Cody says he
received a document that uh quote
contained a screenshot with a do record
addressed to the victim Carrie new
I then contacted Carrie she stated she
did not know how someone was able to
access her mail and she gave no one
permission to obtain access or open her
private mail he concluded that quote
downloading the document involved either
impersonating the victim or lying about
the reasons why the record was being
sought based on the options available on
the Kansas do records website now the
Kansas Motor Vehicles records requires
users to select specific criteria to
access another driver's information
including listing the purpose of the
search however the Kansas Department of
Revenue said that Cody was wrong about
which site zor used quote the service
used in the Marian County situation is
the KD's free license status check which
does not require you to select criteria
for the purpose of checking the status
of an individual's driver's license Cody
doesn't say why he thought zor use the
other website uh but even if she had she
probably didn't break the law the
Department of Revenue said the quote
information from a driver's license
status Checker can be obtained and
reported un legally as long as the
requestor has the required information
in the Kansas statute section section
21- 6107 defines identity theft but it's
hard to see how the facts show that
Meyer or Zorn obtained a document with
the intent to defraud someone in order
to receive benefit and the affidavit
says that new claimed quote she did not
download or authorize anyone to download
any information from the Department of
Revenue and someone obviously stole her
identity but one would hope that the
chief of police actually would know how
these searches work you don't need to
steal someone's identity to access this
kind of information on this website and
many government websites now the
affidavit accuses the newspaper of
violating section 21-
5824 which prohibits certain crimes on
computer including making false
information but again how would the
reporters make or distribute false
information in this case especially with
the intent to defraud Cody apparently
believed that they illegally obtained
the information from a website and then
used it to make new look bad but even
there they're assuming that the
information was true in the first place
now the amount of material and equipment
that the police seized was staggering
eventually endsley filed a motion to
release all the items seized from Meyer
and the judge entered an order to that
effect officers returned some of the
items taken from my's home and office
however the newspaper's lawyer Bernie RH
said that there was a discrepancy
between the inventory the police gave
him and the inventory list filed with
the court a quote the inventory list I
got omits the drive that we now know has
never been returned to us this video
shows the raid on the newspaper you can
see Chief Cody and several officers
taking computers and the police who
searched Myers's home are also accused
of taking photos and bank records now
the amount of material and equipment
that the police seized was staggering
eventually Ensley filed a motion to
release all the items seized from Meyer
and the judge entered an order to that
effect officers returned some of the
items taken from Meyer's home and office
however the newspaper's lawyer Bernie
rhods said that there was a discrepancy
between the inventory the police gave
him and the inventory list filed with
the court quote the inventory list I got
omits the drive that we now know has
never been returned to us now if you've
been raided by a sheriff for First
Amendment activity you'll need a good
lawyer but if you want a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can help if you've
had an injury or death in the family
suffered from a data breach or were
involved in a car crash we can represent
you or help you find the right attorney
it's really important to find an
attorney right away so you're properly
represented just click on the link in
the description for a free consultation
with my team because you don't just need
a legal team you need the eagle team
click on the link below now the city
suspended Chief getting Cody on
September 28th he resigned later that
same day and on the day that Cody was
suspended a local Kansas City television
aired comments by Carrie Newell she said
that after the raids Cody asked her to
delete text messages between them
fearing people could get the wrong ideas
about their relationship Newell told the
record that she complied with his
request but instantly regretted it Cody
did say that he was seeking a warrant in
my PE brain I did not in no instance did
I equate that to a raid and n and Cody
have contradictory stories about who
decided to pursue the search warrant
Cody said that she complained about the
newspaper to him but new said that Cody
called her on August 7th and informed
her that she was the victim of a crime
if somebody tells you that you've you've
had your rights violated she's going to
assume that she's had a rights violent
the Associated Press filed a public
records request which yielded yet more
information about the raid before the
raid he emailed a local prosecutor Joel
Ensley summarizing what he thought the
evidence showed the subject line reads
crimes question mark the other emails
reveal that Cody reached out to the
Kansas Bureau of Investigation seeking
their assistance within the special
agent Todd Leeds replied that he was
forwarding the matter to the special
agent in charge uh for her review Leeds
emailed Cody back on August 8th to ask
for the cell phone numbers Facebook
account names and email addresses for
Newell herbal Meyer and reporter Phyllis
Zorn he said quote I am getting a case
opened up today later that night lead
sent Maran police officer Zack hudin an
email about a search warrant for Meyer's
home quote did you guys execute this
today hland replied no though the
warrant would be executed the next day
apparently none of these public
officials Ever Raised concern concerns
about raing two houses and a newspaper
because the newspaper looked at
someone's uh driving record now the kbi
has refused to comment about its
Communications with Chief Cody the kbi
took over the investigation on August
14th but its earlier involvement with
this case shows that the agency uh is
not an impartial actor and all this
certainly puts Tony mat's comments that
the media isn't above the law in a more
Sinister light publisher Eric Meyer
called for the appointment of a special
prosecutor to handle and distribute the
kba's report uh on the three raids now
the AP obtained video from the raid on
the newspaper office from officer Zack
hudon's body cam it shows him looking
through the desk of reporter Deb Grover
who had been looking into anonymous tips
about why Cody retired as police captain
in Kansas City and the video shows
officer hudin calling Cody over to
review the contents of death drawer Cody
says quote keep a personal file on
the but Hud's clipboard blocks most of
the view of Cody bending over the drawer
and there's no video of that moment from
Cody's own body camera and Grover filed
a federal lawsuit against Cody in his
individual capacity for violating her
first and Fourth Amendment rights I had
my phone in my hand because I was
reading
her uh car's most recent crazy Facebook
post about us all of a sudden you know
the the police and the sheriff's off the
you know sheriff's SUV and all this they
come in at different angles in the
parking lot and they've got all you know
these vehicles up front during the raid
Cody sees Grover's personal cell phone
and according to groover quote Chief
Cody first-h handed Miss groover the
warrant when he arrived and as she began
to read it she began to access her
personal cellular phone telling Chief
Cody that she needed to call Eric Meyer
Chief Cody responded by reaching over
the papers and snatching the phone out
of her hand in this clip you can see the
officer saying that quote the search
warrant covers Us recovering everything
one of the officers also read Miss
groover Miss Zorn and an office
administrator their Miranda writes while
Chief Cody watched though she was never
placed under arrest me that anything you
say can and used can and will be used
against you in the court of law the
complaint says that Cody had quote no
factual basis to Believe Miss gr's
personal cell phone was evidence of the
alleged crime or any crime and alleges
that gr's personal phone was not
verified as having been used to access
the Kansas Department of revenues
records website however quote Chief Cody
sees the phone and removed it from the
premises along with the other equipment
the cell phone was taken directly from
her person not from her desk since Gro
wasn't named in the warrant and her
personal cell phone was not listed in
the application uh groover argues that
the seizure of her phone exceeded the
scope of the warrant violating her
Fourth Amendment the scope of the
warrant only authorized at most a
preview to exclude the personal cellular
phone from seizure and Kansas law
establishes that a person's Mir nearness
to others independently suspected of
criminal activity does not without more
evidence give rise to probable cause to
search that person groer alleges that
the warrant application was both
facially invalid and substantively
invalid facially they contend that a
search made on a public facing website
was not illegal and substantively the
warrant was invalid because quote
existing evidence did not EST establish
a legally sufficient Nexus between the
alleged crime and the places searched
and items seized um in his Facebook post
explaining the raid Chief Cody did not
explain how there could have been
probable cause to believe that Miss
Grover had committed identity theft or
any crime uh Chief Cody also failed to
acknowledge KSA 60- 483 in his post
which provides that a journalist shall
be entitled to a hearing when asserting
a claim of privilege for any information
gathered received or processed now
obviously the first amendment protects
freedom of speech and freedom of press
and as Grover explains rather than
looking for a driver's license
documentation that was the alleged
reason for the raid the officers started
examining records that the newspaper
kept about Chief Cody uh groover
explained the quote in mid to late April
2023 around the time of Chief Cody's
application for the job the newspaper
started looking into allegations of
misconduct against Cody based on
Anonymous sources who had worked with
Cody in Kansas City but declined to go
on record with their claims at the time
the newspaper did not have his personal
file so they did not run a story about
the allegations however according to the
complaint Cody was well aware that the
newspaper was investigating his
background quote specifically Cody was
aware that Miss groover was the one
conducting the investigation having
discussed the investigation with her
around the time of his hiring in April
20123 quote upon belief Miss gr's
affiliation with the Marian County
record which had investigated his
alleged prior acts of misconduct and
recently published a story about Miss
n's prior driving history sparked Chief
Cody's desire for retaliation against
her personally and violation of her
first amendment rights the body cam
footage seems to support this claim
since it showed that officers rifling
through groover's desk and alerting Cody
to the reporter's Files about him
groover left her job because of mental
anguish after the raid you know I
despise him now I mean I didn't like him
to from the GetGo but um I'm I'm I'm
afraid of him I'll be honest I'm afraid
of him I think that
he I think is capable of doing something
far worse to me uh she's been a reporter
for 30 years and on the same day that
she filed the lawsuit she got a tattoo
on her arm that reads freedom of the
press now Cody filed an answer to this
complaint his main defense is that other
people agreed that he had probable cause
for the search he says that he quote
specifically included multiple layers of
law enforcement professionals including
the Sheriff's Office the kbi and the KD
officials and the County Attorney to
establish that the Affidavit of probable
cause and the ultimate search warrants
were appropriate before he proceeded
forward none of the other agencies ever
expressed any doubt that Cody's actions
Were Somehow un lawful or improper now
that's not necessarily a bad defense but
that also doesn't necessarily insulate
him from liability the law enforcement
agencies relied on the information that
Cody provided to them uh and in light of
Cody's answer groover's lawyer might
amend the complaint to add these other
law enforcement agencies as defendants
uh Cody alleges that he had to take
groover's phone because she started to
call Eric Meyer with it during the raid
uh at the newspaper office quote Cody
told Grover not to contact anyone on her
phone during the search warrant process
Grover ignored this request and began to
dial the phone to call Eric Meyer when
Grover ignored this request Cody
confiscated her phone to preclude Grover
from advising Meyer about the police
search because at the same time other
officers were meeting with Meyer at his
home Cody said that he had to remove all
the electronic devices from The Newsroom
because it was taking too long to review
the information they contained quote
defendant Cody had assistance on the
search from the Maran County records
offices from a cyber crime Deputy from
the Marian County Sheriff's Office this
Deputy attempted to merely pulled data
from Phyllis Zorn's computer for almost
2 hours before any computers or phones
were removed from the office the
wireless internet and other data was so
slow to download onto the deputy's
equipment that the deputy advised Chief
Cody that it would be much faster for
him to merely take any equipment that
was possibly involved in the illegal
download uh back to the deputy's office
and search the equipment at his station
only hours after failed attempts by the
deputy to secure data from other
computers on site at the Marian County
record did the law enforcement officials
decide to remove the computers and cell
phones now defend is typically of avoid
giving lengthy responses like this uh in
their answers this is the kind of
response that's better made with
Discovery when you can back up your
assertions with other evidence or
perhaps tailor your defenses to what the
evidence uh comes out uh but obviously
they're trying to counteract the really
terrible narrative that has already been
circulated and you know this seems like
a partial defense to why things were
seized and while it does explain some
things like seizing the equipment it
doesn't necessarily explain why the
search warrant was issued in the first
place uh the plaintiff's lawyer will now
check the body cam videos the paperwork
radio traffic and testimony by others on
the scene to determine if Cody is
telling the truth but this entire
paragraph might not even matter
groover's claim that Cody didn't have
the right to search and seize her
personal cell phone and other material
now Cody denies knowing that groover was
investigating him quote defendant Cody
denies the allegations in paragraph 36
of plaintiff's complaint as it relates
to the allegations that Cody was
knowingly under investigation by Miss
Grover but he then admits knowing that
she was looking into his prior work
history and the hiring process quote
plained groover and defendant Cody
exchanged many emails in the weeks and
months before August 11th 2023 about his
work history interviews about new
officers in the department and a variety
of other matters to date defendant
Cody's email accounts contain absolutely
no emails with pled Grover outlining her
quote investigation into alleged prior
misconduct by Cody but Cody also Reveals
His prior work history includes uh five
instances of Miss cond quote Cody admits
and recalls that during his 24-year
career he received discipline from the
Kansas City Police Department for the
following policy violations one for
using lights but not Sirens when
proceeding through an intersection two
for repeatedly calling a murder
suspect's cell phone to try to convince
him to surrender three for using curse
words against a subordinate that had
broken a chain of command and obeyed a
direct order from him four participating
in a police car chase and five telling
an inappropriate joke now the alleged
reason that reporters at the newspaper
were investigating Cody is because a
tipster told them that he was facing
discipline and demotion for sexist
comments he made to a female officer off
at the Kansas City Police Department and
it appears that that information was in
the file that the police looked at
during the day of the raid now at the
same time it's going to be hard for the
plaintiffs to overcome qualified
immunity now as we've talked about many
times qualified immunity only allows
civil rights lawsuits to go forward if
officials violated a statutory or
constitutional right that was clearly
established and we don't have time to go
into the clearly established standard
but the the federal court will consider
whether a hypothetical reasonable
officer would have known that the
defendant's conduct violated the
plaintiff's rights uh I'm sure Cody will
argue that all of the other local and
state officials involved in the case
thought there was probable cause for the
warrant and that protects him and I'm
sure Gro will argue that they were all
wrong or that they relied solely on
information that Cody gave them and was
uh false or not sufficient and as for
the issue of whether Cody has a right to
seiz groover's phone it also depends on
whether reasonable officer knew he was
violating a clearly established right
now generally police officers cannot
take a mobile phone without a valid
warrant to seize it or search through
its contents you have a right to privacy
that extends to digital information
contained on a mobile phone though there
are some exceptions and groover's
personal mobile phone uh wasn't included
in the warrant application it seems but
Cody says that he had to take it from
her because she was about to call Meyer
but he also claims officers were already
meeting with Meyer at his house uh so in
a sort of A Few Good Men situation uh
it's going to be harder to prove that uh
calling would have interfered with that
investigation but we certainly don't
know what will happen next with this
story or this lawsuit uh but we
definitely haven't heard the last of
this case yeah there's so many twists
and turns to follow I'm probably not
going to have time to cook dinner
luckily I have today's sponsor Factor
because Factor makes meeting your
nutrition goals easier than ever by
delivering fresh never Frozen di
addition improved meals right to your
doorstep and the meals are completely
ready to eat in Just 2 minutes you can
eliminate the hours it would take to
shop meal prep and cook so you can spend
your day doing the things that you
actually want to do too busy this fall
to cook but want to make sure you're
eating well well we Factor you can skip
the extra STP to the grocery store and
The Chopping prepping and cleaning up
too you can relish the best Autumn Fall
flavors with limited time only hearty
comforting meals featuring seasonal
vegetables like cranberry pecan chicken
and apple Dijon pork chops Factory meals
arrived pre-prepared and ready to eat in
Just 2 minutes in the same time I could
even think about going to the grocery
store my factory meal is already done
sometimes I just want a good healthy
meal without having to cook and it's
surprisingly affordable and now Factor
also offers Gourmet plus meals as part
of your weekly options which means you
you can get a little gourmet in your
meal whenever you're craving something
special gourmet meals like surf and turf
or Surf and surf shrimp and salmon
everything really is extremely delicious
and their menus are updated weekly with
34 different options you can choose your
favorite meals or let Factor craft your
order based on your taste preferences
and meal history so give Factor Try by
heading to factor75.com and use the code
legal eagle 50 to get 50% off your first
Factor box or just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description and use the code legal
eagle 50 to get 50% off your first
Factor box you can click right now after
that click on this box over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court